what is your libertarian white
pill what's the thing that makes you the
most optimistic about well I'll say
things are hooded here let me uh let me
give the gene ebstein uh the gene
ebstein case for radical optimism which
I always love this just like speaks to
my soul but so this was his thing that
he said was he was like I hope I do it
justice but he was like okay if you were
sitting around in
1845 and you said uh to your buddy you
went you know I think in 20 years
slavery is going to be
abolished they'd be like you're out of
your mind like the slave trade is like
at the height right now like slavery is
R it's it's just been an institution for
all of human history like what in what
world could you imagine that in the next
20 years across the west and in the
United States of America there's just
not going to be slavery anymore but that
crazy guy would have been right I think
he does one for the Soviet Union too
like if you had been saying in the ' 80s
the Soviet Union was just going to be
gone within the next 15 years it'd be
like totally crazy
and so like it is not there there are
moments like that where things that were
seen as like just inevitable
institutions are just gone and they
don't come back you know and so I would
say right now like look in the year 2002
and I remember you know I'm old me and
Zach are old you're not but now you're
at a point where I could go back 20
years and still I was an adult then um
but I remember the whole year of War
propaganda leading up to the war in Iraq
and like that was just it it didn't
matter if you got your news from Fox
News or the New York Times or MSNBC or
anything it was just unanimous you know
what I mean that it was like hey they
got these nuclear weapons they're
friends with the terrorists they helped
us do 911 we can't let them hand these
weapons off to the Terr you know the
weapons they don't have to the
terrorists who aren't their friends but
they sold the story and there was just
no one else like with I mean there were
other people but they didn't have like a
platform but now it's like you have Joe
Rogan and Tucker Carlson and then just
like a million different shows that have
there's shows you don't we don't even
know about that have half a million
followers there's probably 50 shows that
we all don't know about with half a
million people watching that show all
the time and so much of that those
dissident voices are getting out there
now so I'm like I think for the first
time maybe in human history the Monopoly
of governments over the the you know
like um receiving of information has
been broken I think they're freaking out
about that quite a bit but I think this
is see this is an enormous white pel and
I just hate I also just hate pessimism I
hate it it's like the sorry I was going
to say this is more what I say on my
show I was going to say it's the gayest
thing out there okay is pessimism you're
allowed to say that on our so you will
probably hate mail but I think I I don't
mean gay like being okay anyway uh but
it's just like Le you say the it's just
I don't I just think there's like no
like I got little kids there's no option
for me to be a pessimist like that's
just not an option that's like you know
the I use this uh example sometimes but
it's like an analogy or whatever thought
experiment but like it's like if there
were like five men with guns trying to
break into to my house cuz they want to
kill my wife and kids and I'm there with
with a gun and I just sit there and just
be like I don't know man there's like
five of them and there's only one of me
I just I don't really think I'm going to
win you know it's like what like I got a
away and kids I don't have any option to
feel that way I'm going to right away
start you know it's like okay what are
we doing all right get in the addict I'm
going to snipe him off from here I'm
going you know I got a thing of gasoline
I'm going to make a bomb real quick or
whatever you know but you're trying
something so it's like you don't have an
option to just like feel bad about the
future yeah I mean my my white pill is
very similar uh you know I made a at the
end of the decade I made a kind of like
what was the 2010's all about and it was
called the death of The Gatekeepers that
was when it all started and during Co we
saw them try to come back and they
certainly did I think what was revealed
uh in the Twitter files and all that
shows how close we were to having that
information landscape kind of captured
across all the major platforms and so
didn't happen though uh you know Elon
bought X he's calls himself a free
speech maximalist I don't think he is
but he's at least trying to do something
different there's also now technological
solutions uh you know I'm a big Nostra
fan it's a distributed Network got a
documentary about Bitcoin mining uh that
I'm here in New York for and that's
that's another you know major white pill
is the the loss of control over money I
mean how much more libertarian like
could you get there so between speech
and money uh being uh uncontrollable at
this point I'm pretty optimistic I think
for me it's a little bit different um I
like the idea of like the disruption of
the information industry the disruption
of The Gatekeepers but I think for me
the thing that gives me the most
optimism about the future of
libertarianism is actually oddly enough
the dirt bag left I think we're
currently seeing this weird fracturing
of this sort of wokeness culture that I
think for a long time had really seized
people's hearts and imaginations and you
know a I'm 27 a ton of people my age
were just like totally wrapped up in
this and there was a little bit of this
sense and I know this you know analogy
has really been used far too much but
the sense of like burn the witch and
looking for heresy and then trying to
Stamp Out heresy and trying to ruin
people's reputations and livelihoods to
to the fullest extent possible in this
almost like as if your your heart was
just seized by this fervor this passion
for this you know new religion of
wokeness and I think the thing that
we're seeing that is so wonderful now is
people are realizing how many false
promises that religion uh you know gave
them uh they're realizing a lot of the
lies there they're realizing the degree
to which some of these mob Dynamics can
really turn on them and and you know if
you're in this constant pursuit of moral
Purity where it's not even clear what
these morals are based on on boy have
you really uh been sold a false bill of
goods and landed yourself in a very
difficult situation um so I think the AR
reverence of a lot of the dirt bag left
uh and the sort of people from within
the left who are willing to look at
their own side their own teammates and
say hey what you're doing is just crazy
and frequently they'll do so in almost
the terms that you're talking about the
ones that you know you use on your
podcast and sort of like this boldness
this irreverence um to some degree I
think we're in a moment where like if
you would call the 2010s this era of you
know extreme um overwrought earnestness
I think to some degree the 2020s are
thus far the era of like there's
absurdism uh that's on the rise and I
think you see this a lot with jensy you
see this a lot with the dirt bag left
and I think that it's actually a really
good thing to be able to poke fun at um
you know so much of the [__] that
people were pedaling in years prior and
I think also to some degree as people
get older and like all of us have kids
and so you know whether you like it or
not we have skin in the game there's
more at's a sense of I what the future
looks like I that my son has a good life
um and I think to some degree you also
see there was a lot not just care but
like care like more than I've ever
thought cared about anything care more
about his life being good than my own
life being good I would do anything to
and I think you know any parent feels
the same way but I think there's this
sense of like even if it took you know
Millennials or people of our ref
generation a longer time to get to that
stage and maybe they did that later
they're doing it and I think to some
degree you see people who maybe in their
early were obnoxious you know Lefty
activists who now are raising kids and
seeing kind of the error in their ways
and thinking oh actually I suddenly
value different things than what I
valued before and I think when kids are
taught things that parents disagree with
in public schools or maybe even not
things that parents disagree with but
things that aren't phonics and aren't
math instruction there's a certain
amount of like well an Awakening that
happens a sense of like what lies was I
believing and what lies you know was I
pedaling all along and I think that
we're seeing a lot of this wokeness
crumbling right now um and I'm kind of
delighted by it I look forward to the
ash sheep and hopefully people will
gravitate toward more freedom um you
know and sort of learn the appropriate
lessons from that I don't know if they
will it does seem uh it seems to me like
there's there's like um there's several
different layers of like
unsustainability with this country right
now like there's like the financial
level of like where you could just look
at like numbers on paper and be like
this can't keep going like I don't know
exactly when this house a
yeah like like these entitlement
programs like just look at the numbers
on them this doesn't work and there does
seem to me to be something about wokeism
that is just inherently uh you know like
this this can't continue like this it's
just like this might work for the four
years you're at college or whatever but
like how do you have a life afterward
with this and and it does seem to me
that one of the big like the one of the
big reasons why the the kind of not even
right-winger but the the anti-woke crowd
let's say is is winning in a lot of ways
is just because to to be woke is also it
seems to be miserable like you're just
you're sentenced to like a life of
constantly being miserable over this and
whereas like you know other people can
I'm not saying like I politically agree
with like uh the um like conservatives
but you're allowed to just like have a
family and be fairly happy and not like
you know be at war with every inch of
the world it's a religion with no
Absolution it's a religion with no
Redemption and I think at a certain
point people get a little sick of that
because it's a like you said it's a
miserable way to live and I don't know I
at my core I am a huge Optimist and I
think people frequently try to do good
and I think people also frequently sort
of yearn for um a greater more robust
sense of morality than the weird version
offered to them by wokeism or wokeness
and so I sort of look at the degree to
which some of this is fracturing and
splintering and I begin to feel really
good about it I'm wondering you know how
much more um dii bureaucracy will
various Industries have to deal with
before we essentially realize we're
paying a ton of middle managers and
obscene amount of money hey thanks for
watching that clip from our new show
just asking questions you can watch
another clip here or the full episode
here new episodes drop every week so
subscribe to reent TV's YouTube channel
to get notified when that happens or to
the just asking questions podcast on
Apple Spotify or any other podcatcher
see you next week